si quieren dormir en paz los próximos
cuatro años será mejor que no emprendan
nada kim jong hermana menor de kim
jong-un fue la portavoz oficial que
reaccionó a los ejercicios establecidos
por el sur y eeuu esta última semana kim
jong-un sigue siendo la máxima autoridad
del país pero la hija menor de la
familia sigue haciéndose notar en el
paisaje político y sus amenazas podrían
ser muy serias
encargada para el norte de la histórica
relajación entre los vecinos fue la
primera de la dinastía en pisar el suelo
sureño desde el fin de la guerra en 1953
para la apertura de los juegos olímpicos
en 2018 también se reunió con muniaín el
presidente surcoreano en el marco del
comité de reunificación pacífica de la
patria una paz que no fue muy duradera
cuando con firmeza decidió en el verano
de 2020 volar las oficinas del comité
que calificó de inútiles por otra parte
desde 2015 es la subdirectora del órgano
de propaganda del partido a cargo de la
imagen de su hermano y de la misión de
fomentar el culto de la personalidad de
este expertos ven en ella la mujer más
poderosa de corea del norte nunca en la
historia una mujer estuvo al mando del
país de unos 25 millones de habitantes
pero observadores ven su potencial como
una posible campaña de credibilidad
acerca de los líderes del partido para
hacer la sucesora de su hermano